>> Tucker: LIZ CHEYNEY IS SO
LOATHSOME ON EVERY LEVEL EVEN
WITH THEIR LAST NAME VOTERS
REJECTED HER IN HER REPUBLICAN
PRIMARY SO SHE'S OUT AND HAS A
COUPLE MORE MONTHS IN CONGRESS
AND SPENDING TIME NOT HELPING
THE STATE SHE SUPPOSEDLY
REPRESENTS BUT ATTACKING KARI
LAKE IN ARIZONA?
SO CHEYNEY'S SO OBSESSED WITH
KARI LAKE THAT SHE CUT AN AD
AGAINST HER.
WATCH THIS.
>> I DON'T KNOW THAT I HAVE EVER
VOTED FOR A DEMOCRAT BUT IF I
LIVED IN ARIZONA, I ABSOLUTELY
WOULD.
YOU'D HAVE A CANDIDATE FOR
GOVERNOR, KARI LAKE.
YOU HAVE A CANDIDATE FOR
SECRETARY OF STATE MARK, BOTH OF
WHOM HAVE SAID THEY ONLY WILL
HONOR THE RESULTS OF AN ELECTION
IF THEY AGREE WITH IT AND IF YOU
CARE ABOUT THE SURVIVAL OF OUR
REPUBLICAN, YOU CANNOT GIVE
PEOPLE POWER WHO NOT HONOR
ELECTIONS.
>> Tucker: I'VE NEVER VOTED FOR
A DEMOCRAT.
WELL, OF COURSE LIZ CHEYNEY IS A
LEFT WING DEMOCRAT SO STOP
LYING.
IN RESPONSE TO THAT AD KARI LAKE
WROTE THIS LEVEL TO LIZ CHEYNEY.
DEAR LIZ, THANK YOU FOR YOUR
GENEROUS IN-KIND CONTRIBUTION TO
OUR CAMPAIGN.
YOUR RECENT TV URGING
ARIZONAIANS NOT TO VOTE FOR MES
IS DOING THE OPPOSITE.
OUR DONATIONS ARE SKY
ROCKETINGEN A OUR WEB SITE
NEARLY CRASHED BECAUSE OF THE
TRAFFIC.
CARRIE LIKE IS RUNNING FOR
GOVERNOR OF ARIZONA AND SHE
JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
IS THAT TRUE?
>> THAT'S TRUE.
LIZ CHEYNEY IS OFFICIALLY MY
FUNDRAISER TO DATE, WE RAISED A
HALF MILLION DOLLARS SINCE SHE
DID THE ANTI ENDORSEMENT AND
PEOPLE STILL FLOCKING TO OUR WEB
SITE KARI LAKE.COM AND DONATING.
AN INCREDIBLE BOOM FOR US IN
FUND RAISING.
SO I HAVE TO EXTEND A BIG THANK
YOU TO LIZ.
AT THIS RATE, TUCKER, WE MIGHT
HAVE TO INVITE HER TO OUR
INAUGURAL BALL BECAUSE WE HAVE
TO THANK HER FOR BRINGING IN SO
MUCH FUND RAISING MONEY FOR US.
>> Tucker: YOU WOULD THINK, IT'S
A LITTLE WEIRD SINCE SHE IS A
CONGRESSWOMAN STILL FROM
WYOMING, SHE'S GOT A LOT OF
HOBBIES, SHE COULD BE PLANNING A
NEW INVASION OF SOMALIA OR
SOMETHING, BUT SHE'S ATTACKING
YOU, VERY FOCUSED ON YOU.
WHY?
WHY IS THAT, DO YOU THINK?
>> WELL, I THINK THE SAME REASON
I'M BEING ATTACKED BY THE MEDIA.
I'M SPEAKING THE TRUTH.
YOU TALKED ABOUT IT IN YOUR
MONOLOGUE TONIGHT.
WE CAN'T TALK ABOUT ALL THESE
ISSUES BECAUSE THE MEDIA HAS
TOLD US, THEY'RE PROHIBITED.
YOU KNOW, YOU CAN'T TALK ABOUT
VACCINES.
YOU CAN'T TALK ABOUT ELECTIONS.
YOU CAN'T TALK ABOUT PAUL
PELOSI, NOW YOU CAN'T TALK ABOUT
NANCY PELOSI, AND YOU CAN'T TALK
ABOUT THE ELECTIONS, AND YOU
CAN'T TALK ABOUT COVID.
AND I'M TALKING ABOUT ALL THOSE
THINGS BECAUSE I STILL BELIEVE
WE HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF THE
FIRST AMENDMENT LEFT.
>> Tucker: THAT'S RIGHT.
>> BUT I'M DANGEROUS TO PEOPLE
LIKE LIZ CHEYNEY AND THE FOLKS
THAT SHE HANGS OUT WITH AND THEY
WANT TO STOP PEOPLE LIKE ME.
>> Tucker: WORDS ARE POWERFUL.
I WILL SAY THE LEFT, LIZ CHEYNEY
FOR EXAMPLE, THEY UNDERSTAND
THAT.
I WANT TO ASK YOUR REACTION TO
THIS STORY.
SO RECENTLY THE HEADQUARTERS FOR
KATIE HOBBS, THE PERSON YOU'RE
RUNNING AGAINST IN THE
GOVERNOR'S RACE, WAS VANDALIZED.
THE SUSPECT BROKE IN AND STOLE A
FEW THINGS.
THE SUSPECT'S NAME IS DANIEL AND
REPORTEDLY HE'S AN ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANT TO THIS COUNTRY.
WHAT'S YOUR REACTION TO THAT
STORY?
>> HE'S CURRENTLY IN THIS
COUNTRY ILLEGALLY, AND I HAD
HEARD THAT AS WELL.
BUT, YOU KNOW, YOU CAN'T SAY
THAT NOW BECAUSE YOU CAN'T TALK
ABOUT THAT.
IT'S INSENSITIVE.
AND THE PRESS WON'T REPORT THAT.
AND I'M GLAD THAT YOU JUST SAID
THAT BECAUSE, THAT'S RIGHT, HE
IS CURRENTLY IN THIS COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY, JUST LIKE IT SOUNDS
LIKE WE'VE HAD MANY OTHER
INSTANCES WHERE PEOPLE ARE HERE
ILLEGALLY AND THE REPORTERS
NEVER EVEN ASK THAT.
BECAUSE IT PROVES THE POINT THAT
HAVING A WIDE OPEN BORDER MEANS
MORE CRIME, HIGHER INCIDENTS OF
CRIME FOR AMERICAN CITIZENS AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE SEEING HERE IN
ARIZONA.
AND YOU TALKED ABOUT THE
HOMELESS MAN THAT WAS FOUND, YOU
KNOW, HALF NAKED IN PELOSI'S
HOME.
THIS IS WHY REPUBLICANS HAVE
IDEAS TO STOP THESE PROBLEMS.
I HAVE A HOMELESS POLICY, THE
PRESS DOESN'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THAT.
I HAVE A POLICY TO WORK TO END
CHRONIC STREET HOMELESSNESS, GET
PEOPLE HELP GET THEM OFF THE
STREETS AND RETURN QUALITY OF
LIFE TO THE HARD WORKING PEOPLE
OF ARIZONA.
BUT THE PRESS WOULD RATHER ACT
LIKE THERE'S BEEN SOME WATERGATE
BREAK IN AND MY OPPONENT'S
OFFICE.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHERE HER
OFFICE IS BY THE WAY, I ASSUMED
IT WAS IN A BASEMENT SOMEWHERE.
THEY'D RATHER COVER THAT AND
MAKE UP LIES THAN COVER OUR
POLICIES WHICH WILL ACTUALLY
HELP THE PEOPLE OF ARIZONA AND
MAKE THEM SAFER.
THE PRESS HAS GONE BAD AND THE
PEOPLE ARE AWAKE TO IT.
>> Tucker: THE FACT TO EVEN RUN
SOMEONE AS LAME AS KATIE HOBBS
FOR GOVERNOR OF A MAJOR STATE
TELLS YOU THEY BELIEVE THEY HAVE
THE SYSTEM WIRED, THAT THEY
CAN'T LOSE.
WHY WOULDN'T THEY PICK SOMEONE
THAT CAN TALK?
>> WELL, HER SISTER, HER TWIN
SISTER ACTUALLY, THERE WAS SOME
UNDERCOVER VIDEO OF HER THE
OTHER DAY SAYING SHE VOTED FOR
ME AND I WAS LISTENING TO HER IN
THAT UNDERCOVER VIDEO AND SHE
COULD ACTUALLY COMMUNICATE A
LITTLE BETTER.
I SAID WELL SHE'S OBVIOUSLY
SMARTER IF SHE VOTED FOR ME AND
SHE CAN ARTICULATE POINTS, WHY
DIDN'T THEY RUN HER TWIN SISTER
INSTEAD OF KATIE WHO CAN'T SEEM
TO ARTICULATE EVEN HER POLICIES
BEFORE THE PEOPLE OF ARIZONA IN
A DEBATE.